the one person that is diminishing your
ability to make these dreams a reality
is you because when you state your dream
this is what happens you state it and
then all of a sudden you're present to
how far away you are from it and when
you see the distance between where you
are and where you want to go the
direction that your dream requires you
to walk it you're going to get present
to the gap and that scares us that's
where fear comes into play and you start
to think of all the reasons why you
don't deserve it you start to think of
all the reasons why you can't do it all
that you have to do in order to start to
pursue your dreams is take small actions
every day that align your life in that
direction so what does that mean if you
want to play guitar professionally it
means that you start playing guitar more
it means that you sign up for open mic
nights it means that you go back to
class if that's something that interests
you you see your dreams will happen
either because of you or in spite of you
they don't happen because of other
people they happen because of you and
what you do the second you have the
bravery to state that dream now are you
going to create it or are you going to
diminish it in your mind the secret to
getting everything that you want out of
life is to think big and act small think
big have a huge dream create a vision
for yourself that excites you that you
want to make happen and then act small
don't let the big dream be so big that
it becomes so scary and you never start
find the smallest possible way to just
get started think big act small
otherwise your dreams will stay exactly
that i recently have a guy pop into my
instagram live who was a fitness coach
and he's he's building his success up
and doing one-on-one training fitness
and helping people get results and he
said evan how do i go bigger how do i
build my brand how do i get people to
know me outside of just my my pocket my
community i said well you have to create
content you got to be a thought leader
you got to be an expert i got to see you
doing what you're doing how often are
you making videos
i said well i'm making them once a week
okay great dude
how often do you go to the gym how often
do you work out how often do you care
about your nutrition
i said well every day like you have to
take the same approach
to your business to making content to
being a thought leader said are you in
shape and at the time he's he's
shirtless and then he said yeah i'm in
shape and he he
pans down and you see his abs and then
back to his face he's got the smile on
his face like i love it man
you've put that into your daily routine
you're working out and eating right as
part of your daily routine he said yeah
but it's so hard to
to go off and make videos every day
what are your clients saying to you
about working out and eating properly
that it's so hard dude it's the same
excuses you've already figured this out
in one area of your life the problem is
you're not being consistent in the other
areas that if you want to blow up and be
a thought leader and get a lot of
traction attention and views you need to
get good at the thing you don't become
great at anything doing it once a week
if you believe that you have michael
jordan level talent at something michael
jordan wasn't practicing basketball once
a week you just will never get great at
it you have all of this untop potential
all of this ability to go off and make a
huge impact but we never see it because
you're doing it once a week you just
will never get good at it you'll never
get good enough at the thing if you're
only doing it once a week so he says
what do i do great you put into your
routine you already know how to do this
you just have done it for something else
all of you you've already been
consistent on something
now make this next business goal part of
your daily routine it's thinking big and
acting small most people think big and
have this big vision of where they could
go it's amazing i believe in your vision
i love you i want to see you go off and
crush that huge goal i think you can do
it
but then show me your calendar where are
you taking the action
because most people are spending too
much time just thinking thinking
thinking planning planning planning
you've got to actually get going and
doing it daily consistent small action
one video from my friend who's running
his gym now one video is not going to do
anything
one video one small act is not going to
do anything it's the accumulation of the
daily videos that are coming out the
daily content the daily improvements
that's where you start to build momentum
the biggest thing that's missing from
most of your ideas is momentum because
you're thinking big but you're not
acting small so how do you get started
how do you build momentum i'm gonna give
you a three-step process that i think
will help step number one is apply the
two percent difference the two percent
difference means as soon as you get a
goal in mind most things that we want to
do most people what we what we do is we
think of planning that's step number one
for most people is planning no don't
plan your first step after you come with
an idea is to act
planning is important it's just not your
first step
most people will plan their way to 100
right plan to how i'm going to
accomplish my goal and then they wake up
tomorrow they've lost the boldness they
lock the confidence and they say i'm not
going to do that i can't do that
and there's no momentum and then the
dream dies on the table
the first step is momentum the first
step is action the first step is
figuring out the first two percent
that's it two percent don't plan to 100
instead act on the first two percent why
is it so important because when you're
feeling bold when you're feeling
confident when you get that idea it's
flowing through you right you're in that
energy zone you want to use that energy
to build momentum using that best energy
to go into planning and then you wake up
tomorrow different person
you've lost it all where if you use that
energy into action into momentum then
tomorrow you're gonna wake up and see oh
i've already built some momentum it's
easier to keep the ball rolling the
hardest step is the first one so push
build that first step when you're
feeling the energy so as soon as you get
your next idea apply the two percent
difference your first step is to act
step number two is think about your big
why and little y i'm a big believer that
you have a big mission a big vision a
big thing that you're trying to
accomplish and it's inspiring why do you
do the work that you do because you're
trying to make the world a better place
that's what we as entrepreneurs want to
do that that mission is inspiring it's
amazing it gets you up out of bed
but sometimes it's too big
sometimes you think well who am i to go
off and do that sometimes you think well
other people should do that who have
more money and more funding and more
skills and more knowledge and more
resources i can who am i i can't do that
and so on some days the big why is
actually too big when you're trying to
motivate yourself to get going and take
action the big y might be the greatest
thing of all time but sometimes it's too
big that's where you need the little y
big y and the little y when the big y
seems too big you use the little y
what's the little y the little y is the
small daily little comments that you get
the little pieces of feedback that you
get for me the little y is people who
who read my book trying to find a copy
people who read my book and then they
message me for people who leave comments
on my youtube channel like you guys who
comment down below we read them for
people who dm me on instagram that's the
little why it's knowing that the work
that i do has an impact
because a one-off comment doesn't mean a
lot in the grand scheme of things but i
know that i hit one person however many
views this video gets the people who
comment are way less than the number of
views right that's always the case
and sometimes the views don't make sense
i mean the idea that i get a couple
hundred thousand views a day on my
youtube channel doesn't make sense what
does that even mean i don't know but
seeing somebody comment to say this
video had a big impact on my life thanks
to this video i'm taking action in my
business today like that's that's deep
and meaningful that's the little one so
find the little wide version in your
business you may not think that you're
capable of accomplishing some big thing
every day but knowing that you help one
person can give you the motivation to
get up and do it again tomorrow and
again tomorrow and again tomorrow big
why little why and step number three is
expect to suck at the start this is this
is what really holds people back you
start something you expect to be great
at it it doesn't work out and then you
quit why do you expect to be great at it
it's the first time you're doing it from
my buddy who called into the instagram
live show who's
shredded with his abs and he's gonna
make a video his first video is gonna
suck
right if it doesn't suck he should have
started years ago his first video is
going to suck that's the best
and as kids we know this as kids we try
new things and and we fail at everything
we get up ha ha laugh it off and keep
going but as adults we try something new
and then we fail and then we stop and we
never do it again
then you will never learn anything new
right you're gonna be stuck inside your
box the rest of your life expect to suck
at the beginning it's okay it's normal
doesn't mean you suck as a human it just
means you don't have the skill set yet
how do you get the skill set you
practice you get better you learn you
study you put in the reps
and so whatever it is that you're trying
to take on yes you've got this big goal
big ambitions big dreams i think you can
get there amazing the first start is
right now today what are you gonna do
and in that starting expect nothing to
happen expect just to suck everywhere
you're gonna make your first video it's
gonna be brutal you can write the first
page of your book you're gonna be
embarrassed by it you should be
embarrassed by it's okay it's great the
quality is going to suck the results
will suck but what you want to tie
yourself forward to is the effort that
you did it that you got started and if
you do that every day be proud of your
effort every day i guarantee you're
going to get results
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
when you wake up generally what the
research shows is that your brain is
primed
to be able to focus
for the first four hours of the day
the first four hours of the day tend to
be for most of us
the time of day when your brain has the
most fuel
and when your speed of processing is
awesome and when you are able to direct
your attention at what you
need to be focused on okay
so now there's a caveat to this
you can manufacture
boosts of productivity and boosts of
feeling like you've got a little bit
more brain power
number one immediately after you
exercise so
if you have a burst of cardio 30 minutes
is what a lot of the research says but
if you have a burst of cardio you will
get
a little bit of increase in fuel another
thing that helps is getting outside
getting outside
when you start to feel your energy and
your focus start to go to empty getting
outside is another way to give yourself
a boost of brain power
but generally speaking everybody
you need to start to marry
mornings with peak productivity if you
can own your mornings
if you can put that thing that matters
to you first thing in the morning and
make a little bit of progress on it
you are going to start to feel like you
are more in control you're going to
start to see yourself using your best
brain power and your highest level of
fuel
at the thing that matters most to you we
all know
that we need to love ourselves right
how do you do that um
i don't know
what is the action that you take yeah we
all know we're supposed to accept
ourselves
we all know we're supposed to
uh have self-esteem and self-worth and
self-validation and self-confidence
how do you
build it
and you know the other thing is that we
also are looking outside ourselves
for confirmation validation affirmation
of those things
and so how do you relocate the source of
your self-confidence self-esteem
self-worth self-validation within
yourself so that you're in control of it
big idea right
so uh let me tell you the story about
how i discovered this because it was not
like a oh how do i have another high
five moment you know
i get fired from my talk show
and i
uh am essentially fired from my dream
job
i then start having speech after speech
after speech after speech cancel
then houghton mifflin cancels my
contract for my next book and asks for
me to return money that i've long spent
and why'd they cancel it because because
of pandemic they laid off there are two
reasons first of all they were they were
laying off 45 percent of the staff but
more importantly let me take
responsibility i was a year late on
delivering a manuscript okay so let's be
honest i ghosted my publisher and they
fired me
um as they should the long play to ghost
your publisher right
how about spend your money and then
ghost you
um but
i found myself again in this like
familiar place having sort of
echoes back to a decade ago of oh my god
are we in financial free fall again like
is this ride over
kids come home you did like a hundred
speeches in a year or prior to that or
prior to the show yep and then took a
pay cut to do the show yep
and look i i've been saving money i've
been very smart about about money now
that i've made it we've paid back all of
our debt something we're both really
really proud of
um
and at the same time when it's a fan in
your life your old things will get
triggered and what got triggered for me
is i'm about to lose it all again right
meanwhile just like everybody else on
the planet your kids come home and it's
both a blessing and a horror show to
have your children in a state of
distress as the world is in distress and
i just started to feel overwhelmed
and there was this one morning
where um
i
walked into the bathroom
and i was standing in my underwear
brushing my teeth in front of the mirror
and i looked up at the mirror and my
first thought was
uh
i
noticed that my jowls were starting to
look like saddle bags on a pack horse at
the grand canyon
and uh i had like these crazy lines by
my eyes and my neck was really like kind
of saggy and one boob was hanging lower
than the other and my gray hair was
coming in and i and as soon as i started
kind of critiquing my
thoughts or my looks and appearance then
my mind rich started going i didn't get
that email back to that person and i got
that presentation i need to do and my
god did that speech just cancel again
what am i going to do i look down and
the dog needs to be walked and then i
think i got a zoom call in nine minutes
like i got to get my
and before i knew it my whole mood was
low i felt overwhelmed i had taken
myself down mentally
i just wanted somebody to walk in and be
like mal you it's gonna be okay like you
got this girl like it's lift your head
up you can handle this i don't know what
came over me rich
this is
pathetic
but standing there in my underwear
in front of my bathroom sink
i raise my hand
and high five my reflection
and i cracked a smile because it's so
horny
i even thought of that guy stuart smiley
from the snl skips remember that i'm
nice i'm kind people like me
went on with my day
that was it
snapped a photo though no not that one
oh not that one not the first time and
then
i kept doing it i did it probably for
a week or two
and here's the weird thing about it i
started when i woke up after doing this
high five your own reflection in the
mirror thing
i actually started to feel like i was
looking forward to it
and here's why you know i've spent a
lifetime just like you standing in front
of the mirror and what i realize now is
that when i'm standing in front of a
mirror i'm either critiquing
or picking myself apart
or i'm ignoring myself
and when you start to high five your own
reflection
it starts to build a partnership
within you with yourself
when you walk into the bathroom and you
see your reflection and you've been
greeting it it's like seeing another
person
it's the strangest thing you start to
realize how often you ignore or destroy
yourself when you see yourself or beat
yourself up
and here's what's also crazy
you have a lifetime and this is where
the science gets wacky and i'm going to
hit you with so much science because
this stuff is so cool
you have a lifetime positive association
with high-fiving other people
sure as a runner as a racer
you have gotten so many high fives rich
what does a high five say to you when
somebody gives you one
you feel seen you feel appreciated you
feel energized by it and it's a it's an
exchange of energy it's not the same and
you talk about this in the book it's not
the same as like self-talk because
there's a participation involved in it
there's like a communion yes back to it
yeah and you know if you think about it
you're so good
at celebrating seeing and cheering for
other people in your life you plan
birthday parties you reach out to people
when you're worried about them you help
out colleagues you cheer for your
favorite sports teams you high-five
people like rich as they're running
races past you you buy people's
merchandise you do all kinds of stuff
for other people
but nobody's taught you how to do it for
yourself
in fact the reason why it feels
weird to high-five your own reflection
is because you've been taught to do the
opposite
the reason why those positive i love
myself i'm happy with who i am i accept
myself the reason why those mantras
don't work in the beginning
is because
your brain rejects it
you've spent a lifetime trashing your
body trashing yourself telling yourself
you're stupid telling yourself that
you're not good enough telling yourself
that nothing's ever going to work out
for you there is no way that you're
going to be able to stand in front of a
mirror everybody look yourself in the
eye and say today's the day that i'm
going to forget all that stuff and i'm
just going to accept myself
and the reason why it's not going to
work is because all day long
you then continue to beat yourself up
and so what does work well i'm going to
read from chapter seven
of my new york times bestselling book
the high five habit the place where we
left off for those of you is page 91
where we were talking about training
your mind
to change
the way that it views the world
intentionally training your mind to help
you
and this is an important thing to learn
how to do
because if your mind is going to accept
new ways of thinking and new beliefs
about you you must also train your mind
to start to
see the world differently and so you can
do the exercises that i'm teaching you
in conjunction with what i'm about to
teach you about mantras so
mistake number one when it comes to you
trying to become a more positive person
and when you are trying to change the
way that you talk to yourself is you
pick a mantra
that you do not at your core belief okay
you pick something that is the
antithesis of how you actually believe
it yourself and so the mistake number
one that you're making when it comes to
mantras is that you're picking a mantra
that is so
far away from where you are that your
mind immediately rejects it so that's
mistake number one
mistake number two
is that you pick a mantra
that is simply just you repeating a
statement
that is the exact opposite of how you
speak to yourself and how you treat
yourself all day long and so you know
let me just talk about this on a common
sense standpoint
let's say
that you really want to become healthier
okay
how many of you want to become healthier
right
and you know all the things you need to
do how many of you want to become
healthier and you know the specific
actions you need to take in order to
become healthier
right
of course you know what to do you know
that you could eat
better food
you know that you could get more sleep
you know that you could move your body a
little bit more you know that you could
drink more water you know that you could
lay off the booze and the fatty starchy
foods all those little actions would add
up to a much healthier you
are you with me
yes of course you're with me okay so
knowing what to do is the easy part
knowing kind of what you want that's the
easy part
the problem
with sticking to those changes
is that your own
negative self-talk
trashes you all day long
and the negative self-talk
i'm so fat
oh there i go again i said i wouldn't
have dessert but i did oh i said i
wouldn't drink tonight and i just did oh
i said i was gonna go gluten-free and i
didn't oh i'm sad so i'm gonna do this
oh i don't feel like going for a walk
all of that negative thinking and
talking
it makes you feel less motivated
and less worthy of the change that you
want
and so if you wake up every day and you
have a
dream and a goal of becoming healthier
and you know that today you're going to
move your body and today you're going to
drink more water and today you're going
to cut out the gluten and today you're
going to
do whatever you're gonna you're gonna uh
donate the clothes that don't fit so you
stop trashing yourself all things that
make you feel better right
if you stand in front of the mirror and
you say
i love you and i accept you exactly how
you are
i love you and you deserve to be you
know like and and and i i love myself
and i i i'm gonna be healthy i'm gonna
be the best me i can be
and then the next thing you do is you go
into the kitchen
and you glug glug glug pour a ton of
cream into your coffee
your mind is immediately going to go why
did you just do that oh my god here i go
i'm one minute into this
and your own negative self-talk just
overrode what you said in the mirror
that mantra that i love myself and i
accept myself by the time you got into
the kitchen you have already trashed
yourself
the pouring the cream in the coffee
is an example that you don't love
yourself you're not sticking to your
word and now your motivation goes boo
to change right
this is why most mantras are completely
you're picking something you don't
believe
so what will work
because the truth is
research says that
having a positive attitude
having an optimistic attitude
being kind to yourself
is the secret to motivation and
inspiration
when you treat yourself with respect
when you cheer yourself forward when you
forgive yourself when you screw up you
are going to feel more worthy and you're
going to feel more encouraged and you're
going to feel more
likely to pick yourself back up
dump the coffee with the cream out make
the coffee with the plant-based thing
that you said you would drink shrug your
shoulders laugh that you just
instinctively poured the cream in and
then
there you go
take a sip of your coffee
so we know that positive talk helps we
know that kindness helps when it comes
to motivation
the problem is you're picking a mantra
that is so high in the sky
and it's making you feel far away from
what you want
and so what will work i'll tell you what
works and then i'm going to read to you
from the high five habit
mantras only work
number one
if you believe them
i'm going to say that again mantras only
work
if you believe them
so if you're somebody that has struggled
with self-acceptance
for a very long time
it will not work for you to stand in
front of the mirror when you feel broken
and you're at the beginning of your
journey of taking control of your life
it will not work for you to stand in
front of the mirror and to say
i love and accept myself
because as you stand in front of the
mirror and say that your brain is going
to be like no you don't did you see how
you treated yourself yesterday you do
not love men's accent yourself i know
i'm a ventriloquist now i'm your brain
and then that truth
that your actions don't align with what
you're saying
plummets your motivation and your desire
to change
so what you have to do is pick a mantra
that you actually believe
when i hear the word productivity
i don't want you to think about plowing
through a to-do list
because part of the reason why you don't
feel productive
is because you're busy doing the things
that aren't important to you
yeah do you need to make sure you have
milk or you got almond milk or oat milk
in the fridge of course you do but have
you ever noticed that all the busy crap
in life
uh tends to take care of itself
that you don't really need to focus your
time and energy on the minutia that's on
your to-do list because that stuff tends
to grab your attention
what you really need to do is figure out
how to create time and how to create the
focus that you need
in order to feel like you are making
progress on the important things
and that's really
what productivity means to me
you get all kinds of stuff done you're
really busy in your life aren't you
but are you getting progress made
on the important things
probably not because that's the
challenge for most of us and so first
things first when it comes to trying to
have a breakthrough in productivity you
need a game plan you need to have a very
short list every week of what actually
matters to you okay
because i guarantee you if you were to
do an audit of the way that you spend
your time this week you would probably
see
that 95 percent of your time
is spent on things that you really don't
care about
and even more scary i bet you don't even
realize how much time you are wasting
just mindlessly scrolling through social
media or sitting on the couch with the
tv on also answering emails
that is the least productive way to
spend your time multitasking spending
your time just sort of zoning out on
things that don't matter
what i want you to do is i want you
right now to think about
what is it between now and the end of
this week for example what is it
that matters to you what's the most
important thing
that you would love to make progress on
that you never seem to find the time
okay
it's a whole nother conversation for us
to talk about whether or not you
actually have time because the fact is
you do have time you have plenty of time
to make small amount of progress every
single day on what matters to you
what you do not have right now is you do
not have a plan
for
prioritizing the important stuff in your
life 50 percent of men and women will
not or do not look at themselves in the
mirror
because they do not like the person that
they see
and if you can't even look yourself in
the eyes in the mirror that is a habit
of self-rejection
that means you are starting your day by
rejecting yourself
and that's why so many of us race out
into the world and seek validation from
partners and friends and boyfriends and
caregivers and girlfriends and bosses
because we haven't even given ourself
the respect we deserve
and so i want to teach you how to bring
it back home because for those of us
that look in the mirror
we see the things we don't like
the gray hair the saggy boobs the like
you know dark circles the wrinkles the
turkey neck you know you just pick
yourself apart you don't even realize it
this is part of your morning routine
this is the part where you stand in
front of the mirror and just trash
yourself
we're gonna change that using science
what i want you to do is you're going to
look yourself in the eyes
take a minute that's not a reflection
that's a human being in the mirror and
she needs you
she is tired of your negativity she is
tired of bob running
in your head she's working hard she
needs you to show up
and then you are going to raise your
hand as cheesy as it sounds and you're
going to high-five the woman you see in
the mirror
that's it do not say a word
do not have a mantra
because your brain isn't ready for it
yet
i want you to turn to the person next to
you we're going to count backwards of
five and then we're going to give each
other a high five and i'll explain
something ready turn to the person next
to you yeah i don't don't i was like
here we go five four
three
two
one okay great
okay
so let me tell you what's going on here
let me tell you what i know we got to
wrap it up okay what's going on here is
never in the history of high fives have
you high-fived somebody and thought i
hate you
you look terrible today
if you're in a sports team and you screw
up a shot and you come back to a huddle
what do you hope your coach and your
teammates say to you good good try yeah
and if they hand you a high five to send
you back in the game what does a high
five say
good effort i believe in you keep going
i you know like on and on it is always
positive
remember how i talked about the fact
that your brain is a pattern learning
machine your brain knows the pattern of
a high five
it has a lifetime of experience with
them so all the programming's here
everybody when you stand in front of a
mirror and you physically do a high five
it grabs all the neural association in
your brain and it aims it at your face
literally it shuts down bob broccoli
tomato maria whatever we're caring you
know that we're saying the name is
shuts it down because you can't think
something negative while you're doing
this because your brain won't allow it
it's not programmed that way
it takes less than five days
for you to be able to stare at yourself
in the mirror and see a woman that
you're rooting for
your brain every time you do it gives
you a drip of dopamine that's why you
guys laughed it's not from the slap of
the hand it's what your brain's doing
you feel a little bit energized don't
you
that is your nervous system giving you a
little jolt of energy
the five second rule 54321 and a high
five in the mirror after you brush your
teeth are two free science-backed tools
that you can use to interrupt old
patterns that are holding you back
and to start to create new ones that
will push you forward
because that is where you're headed
we're not looking back
i want you to look forward
and i want you to
quiet the noise shut it down in your
head and listen to what's in your heart
and in your gut
because that's what's meant for you
and all you have to do is wake up every
day and if yesterday blew okay
it was whatever we're gonna shake it off
we're gonna high five that off you
didn't go to the gym no problem you're
still gonna give yourself a high five
today you didn't make that phone call
you said no problem you still get a high
five today because you need to send
yourself into the game of life every day
knowing that you have your own back that
you believe in you
and the way that you prove that is
through the actions that you take
and 30 minutes a day
just for you
to focus on you to set your day up
because how you set your day up is how
it ends up
you deserve that
and that's how you claim it
and trust me you're never going to feel
like it but i want you to do it anyway
you got it got it good
if you expect to achieve your goals if
you expect to
reach your potential if you expect to
have your dreams come true what i'm
about to explain to you is mission
critical
you must become a master
at visualization
now for those of you
that are like what the heck is she
talking about i did not sign up for some
sort of meditation woo spiritual thing
here
don't worry this is mel robbins
there's always science and research
involved in everything that i talk about
so visualization
is a
extraordinarily
powerful skill
and
you may have heard of the law of
attraction
you may have heard of the word
visualization you may have heard of the
word manifesting
i call it um
seeing signs
so i'm a master
at seeing positive signs i am a master
of creating coincidences i have the
world's most incredible luck you want to
know why because i understand the
science and the skill of visualization
i know that your brain
it is a
gigantic
detective machine
your brain is a filter your brain is
constantly looking for evidence
and that's good news it's good news when
you know how to use it to your advantage
let me explain
so
your brain has a system in it here's the
technical term it's called the reticular
activating system
it is a network of neurons all up in
here and what is the job of the
reticular activating system
it is a filter system
it's basically a system that allows
certain information in your brain
and it
blocks out other information
and guess
who programmed that filter
you did
and so did the people from your past
and so if you constantly feel like
you're unlovable guess what your
reticular activating system
is going through the day and it is going
to point out every single piece of
evidence that confirms that negative
belief that you have if you think that
people don't like you at work the
reticular activating system the filter
it is literally going to be looking for
evidence
to confirm that belief all day long
this is one of the reasons why we have
such a problem with politics in this
country this is why there's something
called a confirmation bias confirmation
bias means your mind loves to read
things that you agree with
because reading things that you agree
with
confirms your filter why do we have a
reticular activating system there's a
really important reason why you have
this the reason why is if your brain let
in everything
have you ever looked
at a facebook page
have you noticed
how many words are on a standard
facebook page and the ad over here and
the ad over here and the ad over here
and the ad in the zoom z right here and
the stuff up here and all this over here
if your brain took in everything at
equal value
your head would literally explode off
your shoulders your brain would melt
down and so the reticular activating
system
protects your brain
by filtering information and only
letting in stuff that it agrees with
so
that's the scientific
reason and mandate for why
you got to get busy reprogramming that
thing one of the beliefs that i had for
a very long time is that i was a bad
person
that i was not lovable that um i did not
deserve to be a good person that people
didn't think i was a good person and
consequently that led me to do a lot of
hurtful things to myself it led me to do
a lot of hurtful things to
people that i cared about and it it
really
damaged decades of my life
and i believed it i believed it and it
drove my actions and i saw evidence
everywhere if you're gonna do a mindset
reset you've got to change what you
believe about yourself
and so for those of you that had a very
negative uh
assessment of 2018 and you're feeling
down about your goals already as you
look at 2019 you have a very negative
belief system about yourself and that's
going to stop right now
letting go
is really really hard and when you are
going to start a new chapter in your
life when you're going to try to launch
yourself
forward
it requires you to let go
and the reason why letting go
of whatever it may be a relationship a
friendship a job
my case the place that you lived for the
24 years
the reason why letting go is so hard is
because we tend to grip
very tightly to things that are familiar
and when you grip
really tightly
to the things that you know
it's going to be really hard in fact
it's going to be impossible to launch
yourself forward
and we grip really tightly to the things
that we know
um
because
it feels safe
and the truth is change is really really
really hard
because you're holding on to things that
are no longer meant for you
if this is speaking to you i want you to
write into the comments right now
what are you holding on to
whether it's out of fear or self-doubt
or overwhelm you're just gripping so
tightly
what are you holding on to that you know
is no longer meant for you
i guarantee you you're probably gonna
write a friendship a job
a relationship
uh maybe it's a way of eating or
treating your body
maybe it's a way of thinking that you're
holding on to maybe you're just gripping
tightly
to staying stressed and tense and in a
state of fear
you can hold on to a way of thinking and
that can keep you stuck for decades
i wanted to bring this up because i have
been thinking a lot about this idea of
gripping and holding on
and i think if you if you've followed me
for a while
you've probably heard me say
that you are one decision away
[Music]
from
a different life
better life a life that is full of more
joy
full of happiness full of you feeling
connected and alive and
just engaged in your life again just one
decision away
and the first decision
that will change everything is to let go
to stop gripping
and to find the
confidence and the courage and the
clarity to let go of what's no longer
serving you
and to turn yourself toward what you
truly want in your life tell me is there
some project
or some area of your life
or
a business or a goal
or some change that you want to make
that
you feel
like you think about all the time but
you just can't seem
to push through
all of that thinking or push through the
the the fatigue or the overwhelm or how
do i get started right
you can't seem to just push through is
there some area of your life where you
feel that way
if so i want you to write it in the
comments okay i see i want to work with
animals i see somebody going oh my gosh
i keep thinking about doing a tick tock
account oh i want to get control of my
addiction
oh i want to launch a business oh i
really want to get a degree but i feel
like it's too late
um and you may be telling yourself
uh that uh things just feel like it's
too late now
like i i got a divorce and now it feels
like my life is
frozen i see some of you saying
i feel like
ever since i got the divorce or the
pandemic hit or i lost the job or i took
the wrong job or i moved to the wrong
place or i realized that i wanted to
start this thing and i started it but
now
it's stalled out and embarrassed to keep
starting i want to finish my phd i want
to be persistent with the gym i want to
get back to creating art i see all the
stuff that y'all are writing down it's
beautiful i see so many of you saying
that you have a little side hustle and
you know that you want to turn your
attention towards it but you just can't
seem
to literally push through
whatever it is the fear the overwhelm
the business of your life to laser focus
on what really matters to you
and i think that's why it's so painful
because you're not going to stop
really wanting and longing for those
things that you keep thinking about
everybody
they're going to linger for the rest of
your life
you're going to have to at some point
make a decision
that it is important enough to you
to
make changes so that the thing that you
want to see happen or the life that you
don't want to miss out on
or the degree that you always longed to
get
or the way that you want to feel in your
body or the energy for me a big theme
uh recently has been about loneliness
i am so
lonely in my personal life because
of the pandemic because our kids have
launched because we're moving to vermont
because i'm always working like i can
see very clearly
that i have
tried to solve loneliness in my personal
life by working all the time
and that's not the right solution for
loneliness and so
i even
see all this and so
i'm glad that you can see an area of
your life
where you
feel this friction and tension because
you know that you want to focus more
time and energy there
but there's so much resistance and
there's so much friction and there's so
much else going on that it is robbing
you of the ability
to push forward toward the life that you
really want to be living
and look it's not going to happen
overnight but so let me tell you let me
tell you
this sentence this truth about life that
i truly love that that always kicks me
in the rear end honestly
and here it is
no one is coming
that's it no one's coming
no one is going to come into your life
and do the work for you no one is going
to come into your life and
uh just remove your problems
no one is going to come into your life
and
uh make your dreams come true
when it comes to the changes that you
want to make when it comes to the things
that you long for in your heart when it
comes to the music that you want to put
out into the world or the tick tock
account that you want to create or the
degree that you want to get or the life
you want to build after divorce or after
your partner dies or
after you know you change jobs or after
the kids launch when it comes to those
things that you deeply long for deserve
and desire no one's coming
you are not too late
if you're breathing you're watching this
video you have plenty of time
to create a life that makes you happy to
create a life that is full of meaning
for you whatever that means
you have plenty of time to take control
to heal it is so important for you to
hear that that you have plenty of time
but no one's coming
at some point you have to make a
decision and you'll often hear me say
you're one decision away
from a different life a better life
but you have to make the decision no
one's coming to make the decision for
you you have to decide
that you are done feeling
beaten up you're done
feeling lost you're done feeling stuck
you're done feeling isolated that all
that crap that you've been enduring
you're freaking done
you have to decide that the secret to an
optimistic mindset you got to be
maniacal about your intake
negativity in here means negativity in
your body gets stored here and
negativity comes out here
it becomes this loop of negativity
and so in order to build a positive
mindset i want you to be maniacal about
positive input
that means
really watch your news intake
do not be watching it every day get the
facts
get what you need to know from a trusted
measured
calm
factual source
and then turn that off okay that's
number one number two edit your social
media
anything on your social media feeds
should be
helping you be more resilient
more optimistic
more
um positive
anything
that you're following that triggers you
that is negative that rubs you the wrong
way you know one of the things that i've
noticed
i have some favorite celebrities that i
have um followed for a while because i
think they're funny or i love um
just kind of their sense of humor
but there are so many people that i have
muted right now because i think that
what they're doing online is so freaking
out of whack
seeing people give us advice about
quarantining from the back of their
estates and mansions telling us to
donate when they're not saying they're
donating seeing this kind of tone-deaf
uh celebrity thing going on i'm normally
not a negative person about that but i
have muted muted muted so many accounts
because it's not doing anything for me
and you got to be selfish right now you
have got to edit your social media feeds
so that your social media feeds are
helping you build an optimistic and
positive mindset and so every day the
second i see summer some mute mute mute
mute unfollow unfollow unfollow because
negativity in means negativity gets
stored here but negativity goes out
there from you you want to put
positivity optimism tools strategies
things that keep you laughing keep
things that keep you giving you things
that you can use right now the second
you start getting overloaded with corona
stuff mute that stuff edit edit edit
your social media based on what you need
part of the reason why you don't feel
productive is because you're trying to
complete everything and so let's take
one of the things that i saw somebody
write that you want to uh clean up one
of the spare rooms in your apartment or
in your house that maybe there's a spare
bedroom and you have been wanting to
turn it into a home office or maybe one
of the kids has moved out of the house
and you want to
de-clutter that room like a project
around organizing maybe it's something
in your garage or your basement or hey
here's one for me
our daughter moved out and started her
life uh you know post college and our
other daughter is out in los angeles
going to college and we no joke
have
three garbage bags full of clothes
that somebody needs to go through to
figure out what needs to be donated what
could you actually sell because it still
has tags on it and it has been sitting
there for two months so maybe you have a
pile of that kind of stuff in your house
this is not a priority for me i'm
perfectly fine with it sitting in the
room where our laundry is the priority
for me this week is to carve out
dedicated time to hang out with our 16
year old son and do something fun
together because we spend a lot of time
together but we don't get intentional
about doing something specific but if
you want to declutter for example here's
where we all go wrong you identify what
you want to do and then you think you
got to get it done
in order for me to go through two bags
of clothing for example in order for you
to clear out your garage
that could take you two days to do it
the right way right
because
you know if you don't give yourself
enough time then you're gonna piles and
so then you think i can't get it done
and so then you never schedule it right
okay we're not going to worry about
completion everybody
we're going to worry about progress
so when you think about things in terms
of progress it can shrink the amount of
time that you need
maybe all that you're going to do is
you're gonna work on one dresser in the
room
or you're gonna work on one shelving
unit in the garage
and by simply making the time to number
one identify what matters to you and
number two identify what meaningful
progress could look like
you will now shrink the amount of time
you will define the project and you can
make the time for it and simply just
doing that is going to make you feel
more productive based on the research
all right now let me talk about um
what you need to do okay i literally
have notes for this oh there we go and i
just lost it because i really want to
make sure that i teach you all this
stuff
so um
here becca can you help me because this
is not because my thing is not never
mind guys i am tr i am trying
multitasking is not how you be
productive and you are watching me
multitask right now
we're going to get into some of the
science now
so now that is how you leverage
something called the progress principle
okay the progress principle is really
important when it comes to productivity
this is a concept that i first learned
about in the harvard business review so
if it's in the harvard business review
everybody very fancy must be accurate
right if it's coming from harvard well
the progress principle is a study that
uh comes from a study where researchers
looked at i believe it was fourteen
thousand work journals and what they
found after looking at the work journals
of how people spent their time fourteen
thousand people is that at the end of
the week the people that felt like they
had been the most productive and the
people who felt the most fulfilled by
their work week were the people who
simply made progress
on something that mattered and so by you
identifying what matters to you this
week and by you identifying a way that
you can make a small amount of progress
on it you are leveraging this research
research from harvard business review
about what creates productivity and
meaning and fulfillment in your life and
that's making progress on something that
matters you need to do the work okay
you got to do the work because it's only
through your actions that you will
accomplish what you want let's say uh
that you've always wanted to climb a
particular mountain okay there's a
mountain called haystack it's not even
that tall so i should probably pick a
bigger one but let's just call it
haystack mountain you've always wanted
to climb haystack mountain you pull up
to haystack mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know national forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my god
that's a really far way away
you know i don't really know how i feel
about doing this anymore because that
looks like it's going to take a really
long time
and then all of a sudden it starts to
rain and you go i don't think i want to
do this because i don't think i feel
like doing this and next thing you know
you are back in the car driving back
down the road to that little diner that
you saw and instead of climbing the
mountain that you've always dreamt of
climbing you've now
come up with an excuse
and you have abandoned ship you now have
literally become your own obstacle you
talked yourself out of it you started to
doubt yourself you told yourself you
weren't ready and that you didn't feel
like it
you pull the rip cord you're out of
there in order to have what you want in
life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain
you must stop creating excuses for why
you can't or don't feel like it and you
must put your head down and look at the
first step in front of you
and then you must take the action and
start walking toward what you want and
it'll be a hell of a lot easier for you
to do that if you have also
been putting in the time every day
consistently to not only see yourself
walking up that trail step by step but
that you have felt yourself pushing
through the resistance the fear the
obstacles the
the excuses that are stopping you now
and feel proud in every fiber of your
being as you push through those
obstacles and see yourself and feel
yourself doing the work that's how you
manifest properly
and if you do that before you pull into
the
national park parking lot
if you look up at that mountain and you
see clouds and it starts raining it
won't matter
because you've already rehearsed this
moment in your mind body and spirit
and you my friend will start walking up
that trail
and you're going to be proud the reason
why visualization and picturing yourself
succeeding and allowing yourself to feel
the happiness and the pride that comes
with picturing a positive future
the reason why that's as important is
let's say shelley does that every single
day this week
every day she wakes up she walks for
five minutes and as she's walking on
that treadmill she's visualizing herself
finishing a 10k in six months and how
proud she is
every time she does that she is
changing what's going on up here
this isn't something i made up this is
true
and it's not only true based on science
but let's think about this from a common
sense perspective if shelley wakes up or
if you wake up every single morning
and instead of thinking about the worst
case instead of looking at your body in
the mirror and going i'm so fat i'm so
out of shape i'll never run a 10k this
is never going to happen why didn't i
exercise last year i hate my flabby
stomach i hate my my big thighs i hate
how out of shape i'm embarrassed to like
if that's what you're thinking
then that is what
you're allowing your brain
to continue to filter the world through
if you start
teaching yourself the skill of
visualizing a positive outcome and
feeling the pride that comes with
achieving that positive goal what
happens for you right now
is you start to think like the kind of
person that does a 10k
if after an entire week what shelly does
is she get looks in the mirror and she
goes i'm getting stronger every day i'm
really proud of myself even though i'm
i'm feeling flabby i'm not saying you're
flabby shelly but even though i'm
feeling flabby i'm doing the work i can
do this what happens a week from now is
when she sees a registration for a 10k
the old mind that wasn't programmed
correctly would go oh you're fat you're
out of shape you're not prepared for
that don't sign up
but the new mind
because she's been visualizing every
single day
the new mind just seven to ten days
later is gonna go oh wait a minute i'm
in shape i'm proud i'm doing this why
don't you sign up it's going to filter
the world in a very different way
because you're training it to
this is the heart of doing a mindset
reset and this is why visualization
works and why it's an important step and
why i'm so glad you're doing it if you
struggle with boundaries i want you to
know you're not alone and this is super
common
and um one of the reasons why i'm
excited to share everything that i've
learned about boundaries with you is
because i used to be the kind of person
that had zero boundaries i mean nada
nothing zilch nothing in fact there were
periods of my life where it was worse
than zero because i was so attached in
romantic relationships that i literally
would become like a human amoeba
in my romantic relationships i mean i
was like literally if it's possible to
have negative boundaries meaning you
like somehow go in a totally different
direction
that was me and so if somebody as
insecure
and as uh emotionally attached in
relationships and as people-pleasing as
me can figure out how to
identify
communicate
and uphold boundaries in my life
you can learn how to do this too okay
and so that's what we're gonna unpack
in this video
so i think a big question because a lot
of people talk about boundaries they
know they need boundaries but
they don't
have good boundaries why is that
well the reason why
we don't have good boundaries is because
none of us were trained how to set them
i mean i want you to think about your
childhood for a minute
your childhood with your caregivers your
parents or grandparents whoever
it is naturally an imbalance right like
when you come into this world you are
born into a particular family you're
born into a particular culture religion
economic situation a place in the world
a race like a religion and based on
where you were born and to whom you were
born into in terms of the family
structure
there were all kinds of rules that you
had to follow and if you did not follow
those rules
there were consequences
and so can you imagine
if you as like an eight-year-old started
to try to express boundaries literally
like mom cooks a uh you know a pot pot
roast dinner and you cross your arms
you're like you know mom
uh this is a boundary cross for me i
have decided that i'm no longer eating
meat
uh your mom would probably go guess what
youngster
you not eating dinner is a boundary
crossing for me you're not getting up
from this table until you finish what's
on your plate and so
saying boundaries when you're little
doesn't really work for the adults in
your life and that's why you never
learned how to do it and by the way your
parents were probably never taught how
to have boundaries either and so
i want to start at the very beginning
okay
where do you even begin
where do you even begin when it comes to
learning how to set healthy boundaries
okay
so
first things first where you're going to
begin is you're going to start to think
about boundaries in a completely new way
okay
the number one mistake that we all make
i made it you're making it right now is
when you think about boundaries you are
thinking about other people first okay
you're thinking about boundaries uh and
believing that your boundaries are rules
in a relationship that define respect
and that somehow your boundaries are
going to control or change someone
else's behavior
that is the exact opposite of how you
should be thinking about boundaries okay
and i'm going to give you a bunch of
examples don't worry i didn't realize
this this is why i was lousy at setting
boundaries because i thought that my
boundaries control what other people do
no no no no no so how do i want you to
think about boundaries okay
boundaries are rules
that you create
about your own behavior
yep i'm going to say that again
boundaries are rules that you create
about your own behavior
you can find people to support you
you will always find people to criticize
you
watch though how when somebody outside
of you criticizes you
how that triggers the internal pattern
so what is the pattern that you have of
thinking
that gets triggered that disempowers you
that i won't have any words you won't
have any words let's go deeper than that
is it something about being loved or
being unworthy or not being good enough
what is underneath i won't have the
words
yeah they won't be the right words and i
it won't be good enough yeah okay and so
do you have an opinion that you're not
good enough or not deserving of success
or that you're not
smart enough to make a difference
yeah what is the one what is what is the
thing that hooks you
that you say to yourself
that i'm stupid that they're okay there
we go that's a good one not a good one
but you know what i mean that's a good
one because
okay i'm a piece
now we're talking yeah that's the big
one who told you that
i don't i don't know who told me that
when did you start believing that
so it's a little girl yeah
god i've just been saying it for so long
i i don't know that's okay she said i've
been saying it for so long i don't know
as you now know what you're looking for
you're gonna start to connect the dots
okay and so here's the thing
at some point
you started telling yourself whatever
i'm a piece
as a strategy
you did it on purpose as a youngster
as a way to survive things that were
happening because maybe when you said
well i'm a piece you actually got really
quiet and you didn't get hit or maybe
when you said that you uh removed
yourself from situations
when you would have been abused or
something it worked because it protected
you as weird as it sounds yeah is that
are you seeing something what are you
seeing
well yeah my dad didn't want he wanted
me to be quiet in the corner being quiet
yeah he couldn't
make noise and okay
and if you got if you raised your voice
you got in trouble
so do you guys see the link now between
why she has a concern about finding her
words
oh yeah i didn't get that one you see
that now yeah so
every time that you are in a situation
where you need to speak up how many of
you relating to this by the way
i have a theory about all of us
that we have
patterns and strategies that we we
created when we were little
in order to survive situations
and what she
internalized was don't speak up
and you're a piece you do
and
believe me that protected your ass it
worked because you didn't speak up and
you didn't get in trouble with your dad
right and i still got the love so if i
speak up now i'm going to lose my dad's
love do you see this
so this is a pattern that got
written
when she was little
and it was written by someone else and
it worked it worked
the problem is now that you're working
now it's not working now
it's not working now not working now and
see
exactly and so this is what's
fascinating about all this there are
places in your life where you have
patterns that you don't even recognize
that were strategies that you developed
when you were a kid and so in the areas
where you're really frustrated that
pattern is probably
not
present or conscious
something that you're aware of
and so every single time because you've
been repeating this and repeating it and
repeating it every single time you're
about to hit play every single time
you're going to stand on a stage what's
going to be right there is don't speak
up you're yes freeze and you're gonna go
five four three two one the only thing
to
that actually overrides this pattern is
to speak
and through speaking
you will see that you're not a pc
you actually have something to say
or you could make fun of it and say well
i guess i'm just a piece of something to
say
that's gonna be my thing
[Applause]
that's right and i also like the
strategy of kind of making the fun of
the stuff
even the heavy stuff
because it loses its grip on me it works
for me it may not work for you
but it's something to try okay you got
it thank you and if you want more fire
and espresso videos check out the one
that we recently did the link is right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there